the commander of Ukraine's Ground Forces
says his troops are advancing on the
Russian occupied city of bakmut in the
East he says forces have already
destroyed a Russian position near the
city meanwhile Moscow says it stopped a
major Ukrainian offensive in the Eastern
Donetsk region those reports have not
been independently verified but Moscow
has released pictures it says shows some
of the fighting authorities say 250
Ukrainian troops were killed and 16
tanks destroyed
in total the enemy deployed six
mechanized and two tank battalions the
enemy's goal was to break through our
defenses in the most vulnerable in its
opinion sector of the front the enemy
did not achieve its tasks it had no
success as a result of capable and
calculated actions of the group of
forces East the Ukrainian Army suffered
losses of more than 250 people 16 tanks
three armored personnel carriers and 21
armored vehicles
pro-ukraine Fighters have launched a
raid in the Russian border region of
belga Rod one of the groups involved the
Russian volunteer course says it's
captured several Russian soldiers it
says it's ready to hand them over to
Ukrainian authorities
of the second group involved in the raid
Liberty of Russia Legion released this
video is as the footage shows Fighters
carrying out the raid in Belgard the
Russian defense Ministry says that
attack was repelled
let's join our correspondence in Keith
now Charles Stratford Charles it's very
difficult to get a clear picture of
what's actually happening on the front
lines in Ukraine what are you hearing
well so far as expected there's been no
official comment on these claims by the
Russians from the Ukrainian military or
the Ukrainian authorities in fact in
recent days the Ukrainian government
Ukrainian military has launched what can
only really be described as a campaign
warning the public and the military to
maintain silence on any kind of military
movements in these areas along the front
line because of course the element of
surprise is so key to their AIMS in this
expected counter-offensive so we can't
verify independently what has gone on
but these are some fairly strong claims
being made by the Russians five sectors
according to the Russian military
defense on the front in the southern
Donetsk region an attempt there they say
by the ukrainians to push forward
they've released as you mentioned some
video which shows a a green field and
what looks like military vehicles being
destroyed being targeted but of course
we can't verify where that is or indeed
who those military vehicles belong to I
think what's interesting though is that
this claim of buy at the Russian forces
that this attack happened in the
southern Donetsk region that is uh not
to be completely unex affected because
there's been a lot of speculation by
military analysts and by Western
intelligence agencies is that when this
counter-offensive is launched there's
going to be a lot of focus by the
ukrainians on trying to push through
from zapparesia and Southern donets to
try and connect go through Russian
occupied territories and get to the ads
of sea and by doing that cut off this
so-called land bridge between occupied
areas of Donetsk and lugansk in the
north with occupied Crimea but as I say
at this at this stage it is impossible
to verify whether indeed this attack
happened or whether indeed it is part of
the initial stages of this long-expected
Ukrainian counter-offensive what are the
challenges Charles of the the ukrainians
are facing we're launching this
counter-offensive
there are huge challenges that they face
Laura analysts will tell you that these
include fears that uh a lot of the the
Western military kit or the kit that has
been supplied to Ukraine by its allies
could be spread too thinly along this a
thousand kilometer front line then of
course there is the element of surprise
maintaining that element of surprise
when of course there's been such long
speculation over this counter-offensive
that has given Russian forces such a
long time to be able to dig in they're
very well defended it's understood
certainly satellite imagery would
suggest that certainly in the South
we're expecting to see if indeed this
counter-offensive has started or when it
does start analysts will tell you that
they're expecting to see little pushes
by the Ukrainian forces as decoys if you
like to try and distract attention from
major pushes potentially happening in
other areas also analysts talk about the
challenges of what they call
simultaneous complex military attacks
thus far in this war analysts will say
that the majority of Ukrainian strategy
has been well what they describe as
sequential that means that the
ukrainians will start hitting Russian
positions with artillery for example and
then after that try some sort of
infantry device a complex
simultaneous military move is far more
difficult to achieve and then of course
there are huge fears about air defense
as well we know that Ukrainian forces
are lacking in that area too so yeah the
Ukrainian forces are facing huge
challenges with this counter-offensive
but as I say whether or not it is
actually started or not is very
difficult to verify okay for the moment
Charles Trafford thanks very much for
bringing us the latest from Keith